a platinum rank League of Legends player
in Taiwan has bought a pro team and made
himself the starting jungler on the
roster his name is God tone he's an
online Mega celebrity and you're going
to want to strap in for this story
because it really is a mad one
[Music]
but here's what you really need to
understand in Taiwan God tone is
unbelievably big he's been called the
tyler1 of Taiwan but honestly I think
that's a little bit of an understatement
he's been a League of Legends content
creator for the past decade becoming
famous in Taiwan as a High ELO gragas
one trick and to this day a particularly
smooth gragas combo is also known as a
god tone on the server he's also known
simply sometimes as the god of Asia but
he's not just known for his skills with
the barrel God tone is somewhat of a
living me montages of him have racked up
millions of views showing off his skills
his laughs his rages and watching them
it's easy to see why he's known in
Taiwan simply as the king of mouth
foreign
[Music]
clip of him being annoyed of former pro
toys for licking his lips
was spun off by the Taiwanese Lee
Community into some pretty bizarre
memory
he's even doubled in Street Fighter and
took part in the Taipei major in 2019
where he cosplayed as his character
birdie to put it simply the 34 year old
has been around the Esports block so
yeah he's basically a massive online
celebrity and although he's never really
been predictable a lot of people were
surprised to hear in January that he was
going pro in League of Legends now this
is a shock for two reasons firstly
although godton may have had a much
higher rank in season's past he
currently reportedly sits in Platinum I
don't think you can say that about a
single other Pro and secondly he didn't
just join a team as a pro this is where
it gets really interesting on January
12th he announced the founding of Hell
pigs otherwise known as HPS created From
the Ashes of meta Falcon whose slot they
taken in taiwan's PCS League he then
gave a jokey rundown of the roster
including himself as the jungler in
which he compared himself to Dwight
Howard an American basketball player for
the Tao Yuan leopards in Taiwan the post
received over 29
000 likes the hype was real the meme God
himself was about to enter professional
League of Legends as both the owner and
jungler of a team a reported 80 000
viewers tuned in to watch his debut at
the end of last month to put that in
perspective that's over 10 000 more than
the average concurrent viewers the LCS
gets at the moment God's Own is massive
so the next question is obviously how
has the team been doing well the PCS has
only just finished week three of their
summer split but things are going
relatively okay for them if you consider
the absolute jungle Canyon between them
and the rest of the league they're
currently sitting in sixth place with a
three and six record they're not bottom
of the pack and have actually been
improving in recent weeks week one saw
them go zero wins three losses week two
they went one win two losses and week
three they managed two wins one loss now
I call that an upward trend godton is
sitting at a 1.62 KDA which is
significantly lower than the League's
average of 4.08 and his kill
participation is at 50.7 compared with a
League average of 70.63 now he has had
some incredibly rough games like his
week one oh and six sejuani performance
that just went from bad to worst but
last weekend he pulled out the Nautilus
jungle and put up a three kill to death
14 assists performance to help his team
to a comfortable Victory so on paper and
at least by my eye test it's not really
looking great now some people have said
that he is at least hanging with the
other Pros I think that might be a
little bit of a stretch but he's
certainly not being demolished quite as
hard as you'd expect given his alleged
Rank and let's talk about that rank like
I said earlier I can't think of a single
Pro in League of Legends history that
began there a pro career as Platinum the
Reddit post have brought this story to a
lot of Western League fans like myself
stated that God tone was Platinum but
offered no sources so after spending a
lot of time with Google translate I
found a Taiwanese article from last
month which claimed to have found two of
godton's accounts one of them known in
English as ghost news red ant does
indeed appear to be the same one he uses
on stream and yes it is currently
Platinum too the article also claims
that this is his off Stream Account
which is currently Diamond one but it's
harder to verify it belongs to him if he
does only play it off Stream So as I'm
unable to confirm that the diamond
account is his it does look like the
only verifiable account he has is
platinum now my first thought here is
how is this even possible the LEC the
LCS the LPL even the emea all have rules
that state a player must be at least
Diamond one currently or at the end of
the previous season in order to be a pro
player but try as I might I could not
find the rule set for the PCS I spent
way too long looking for it so I have to
assume one of three things is happening
here either the PCS doesn't have that
rule or there's an exception to the rule
for owners playing on a team or God tone
does have an account that meets the
criteria such as the alleged Diamond
account I'm a bit confused here but then
again a lot of things confuse me with
this story and that's not necessarily a
bad thing it's all just highly unusual
when I first heard about all of this I
have to admit I just thought it was some
rich guy trying to buy what skill alone
couldn't get him and while there still
may be an element of that going on for
me I'm not quite as skeptical about
godton as I initially was I see a guy
who's been a key figure in the Taiwanese
League Community now for over a decade
doing something pretty interesting which
is more than I can say for most other
leagues out there right now he's
generating views and attention that
would make most major regions blush and
he's turning a lot of heads outside of
Taiwan it's made that region slightly
more interesting for me I may actually
watch some PCS games now that I know a
bit more about his story perhaps some of
you will do the same because if hell
pigs do continue to improve and so does
their meme God streaming Platinum
jungler then I want to see just how far
this bizarrely wonderful story can go I
for one can't wait for the godton faker
showdown at Worlds this year I'm kidding
of course but just like Faker I think
I'm going to keep an eye on him just in
case
I just think this guy's kind of amazing
because he helps answer that question
that all of us have asked at some point
in our gaming careers which is how would
I stack up against the very best you
know the absolute Pinnacle of Esports
the pros